Speaker 1: I am going to play a video video for
you from Fox News that makes it very clear. Fox
News is positioning itself to hit the abort button
on supporting Donald Trump. They're getting ready
to dump Trump and support Ron DeSantis in 2024,
but they're leaving themselves an open window
to support Trump if Trump is the nominee. So if if
you were doubting that Fox News would rather Trump
not be the nominee, check out this deliberately
edited Man on the Street tape segment where Fox
News reporters went out and they were talking
to random Trump voters. And the question was,
do you want Trump to run again or not? And of
course, they could have crafted this in any way
that they want. You can just keep interviewing
people until you get the clips that you want.
They selected mostly random Trump voters
who don't want Trump running in 2024. It is
very clear that Fox News is setting themselves
up to abort the Trump train. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: I don't want them to. I like like
what he stands for. Like where he does. But
he upset too many people and the absurd
and really bad. So I think he's good for
the party. He needs to get back in that he
already had gained that respect from all the
world leaders and finish what he started.
Speaker 1: By the way, that's the random
Trump supporter in there. He gained respect from
world leaders. World leaders were laughing at him,
literally both behind his back and sometimes
to his face, behind his back at a number of
different summits, to his face at that
wacky U.N. speech where the room just
started laughing at Trump. Respect.
Speaker 3: It's too bad that he
did what he did do and was fought the whole way
along on darn near everything that he did. But
that's what happened. So I'd like to see him
not run. If he did, I would vote for him,
but I would not recommend he runs. I voted
for Trump both times and I love him. I think
he was a good candidate, but I think his time has
passed. I couldn't care less about President Trump
personally. I'd prefer somebody different. But
if he is the nominee, I'll probably vote for him.
You know what? I voted for him for my very first
time. I voted for him. I don't think he'll be best
for our country for him to run for reelection. You
know, I'm thankful for everything that he's done.
But I think our Republican Party needs to
be united. At this point, he's a little too
polarizing. And I think that there are candidates
out there, Republican candidates, obviously, that
may be able to pull in people that he would lose
to be able to change this. I would like to see,
you know, Governor DeSantis or someone like that,
some some new blood in the race the senator's
representing. If he wants it, then he could pick
up Donald as a vice president. We're from Florida
to Santos. We're big fans of the Santos. And this
one, he seems to be much more in common sense
and able to communicate better to both
sides to get those people back there.
Speaker 1: To remember they could have picked
anybody they could interview. They're only
including a few people in this. They could have
interviewed 50 or 60 or 70 people and gotten
whatever they wanted. Everybody saying Trump
should run or not, everybody saying this. They
have chosen these people to create this story.
Speaker 3: And this switch. He's done a
good job and everything he's tried to do
despite all it's not all just what he says
doesn't just happen like that. I believe he's
done a good job with a lot of things. And. Just
my personal beliefs. I really like to. Santos.
Speaker 1: All right, so you get it. Fox is in
total control of this story. They could make
it say anything. They could turn it into a
campaign ad for Trump if they wanted it. They
are looking towards the future. They seem to
think the future is not Trump. And the long term
viability of Fox News as a business enterprise
depends on it being sort of like the state media
arm of some Republican authoritarian regime.
And so this is self-interest at work. I want
people to understand that it's not about
they like Trump's foreign policy or they don't
like it or whatever. The idea here is they want
to get someone other than Trump in. If
Trump ends up winning the nomination,
of course they will still back him. But right
now they're saying we think we will be better off
with the old version of Fox, where we just all
get behind a more popular authoritarian right wing
regime rather than someone who's as polarizing.
And so they've crafted this narrative everybody
seems to want to Santos. We will see how the
primary shakes out if and when people announced.
Neither Trump nor DeSantis have yet announced, but
this is probably part of why Trump would rather
make the announcement sooner than later that he's
running, and it will be to his advantage in order
to push people to have to take more of a risk to
not support him right now with no one declared.
It's easier for Fox to run these pieces. Hey,
look, it just sort of seems like the public
wants someone else and that someone else happens
to be Ron DeSantis. If Trump announces, it puts
them in a much more difficult position to keep
running anti-Trump pro DeSantis pieces. So that's
to Trump's interests then to announce sooner.
Every indication is that he's going to do that.